افادت مراسله الجزيره بان الجيش
الاسرائيلي نصب حواجز واغلق طرقا رئيسيه
في غلاف غزه واعلنها مناطق عسكريه مغلقه
ومن هناك تنضم الينا مراسله الجزيره نجوان
السمري ماذا في التفاصيل نجوان عن اغلاق
طرق رئيسيه واعلانها مناطق
عسكريه نعم بالفعل هناك عده حواج جز نصبها
الجيش الاسرائيلي في مواقع مختلفه في
المناطق القريبه من الحدود مع غزه تحديدا
المناطق التي لا تبعد اكثر من ثلاثه
كيلومترات عن السياج الحدودي واغلق عده
محاور طرق رئيسيه وبعد التحقق يبدو بان
هناك حدث يشارك فيه اسرائيليون متعلق
بالطبيعه ولذلك من الواضح ان هناك حاله
استنفار قصوى في هذه المناطق لاسما وانه
منذ ساعات الصباح التي وصلنا فيها الى
مناطق تقابل المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه
تحديدا منطقتي بيت لاهيه وبيت حنون اي
كانت هناك عده مرات قسف مدفعي على مواقع
مختلفه في هذه المناطق والان نرى ايضا سحب
دخان اي تتصاعد من منطقه تحديدا بيت حانون
جراء هذا القصف بالاضافه ايضا الى تحليق
للطي ران الحربي ومسيرات
عسكريه في هذه المواقع ربما في الاسابيع
الاخيره الماضيه كانت مثل
هذه العمليات للجيش الاسرائيلي سواء كانت
القصف المدفعي او التحليق للطيران الحربي
فوق المناطق الشماليه قليله جدا وقد
تراجعت بعد ان تم الاعلان عن الانتقال الى
ما يعرف بالمرحله الثالثه في هذه الحرب
وهي المرحله التي تكون يكون فيها عمليات
محدوده ومحدده الاهداف وفقا لبيانات
المتحدث العسكري الاسرائيلي واقل كثافه من
حيث القصف المدفعي او القصف الجوي لكن
ايضا لا يتوقف صوت الاشتباكات بالرشاشات
الثقيله في مناطق مختلفه تحديدا تاتينا
هذه الاصوات من منطقه شرق جباليا و من
الواضح ان هناك ايضا تدور اشتباكات في هذه
ال اثناء فدا بالاضافه الى الاشتباكات
المتواصله والقتال الضاري في منطقه خان
يونس ونرى ايضا ان هناك قصف جوي بداه
الجيش الاسرائيلي في مناطق مختلفه في
المناطق الجنوبيه في منطقه رفح لانه حتى
الان ايضا لم يحسم قضيه العمليه البريه او
المناوره البريه والانتقال الى هناك في
هذه المرحله رغم ان وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي يوم امس الاول اعلن وهو في
جوله تفقديه في منطقه خان يونس بان الخطوه
التاليه بعد ان تم تفكيك ما او ما قال
انها تفكيك للاطر العسكريه وللكتاب
والاليه التابعه للقسام في منطقه خان يونس
فان الخطوه التاليه ستكون رفح ورغم ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي قد وضع خطه عسكريه
وعمليات للتعامل مع رفح الا انه لم يتلقى
خطه سياسيه بشان ذلك من القياده السياسيه
ومن الواضح ان هذا يتعلق ايضا بعده امور
ترتبط باي عمليه عسكريه في منطقه رفح ب
بسبب اولا الخلاف مع مصر حول هذه القضيه
ولكن بالاساس تواجه اسرائيل مشكله وسؤال
لا تستطيع تقديم الاجابه عنه اين كيف سيتم
التعامل في مع عمليه بريه وسط كل هذه
الاعداد الكبيره للنازحين الفلسطينيين في
منطقه
رفح هناك سؤال هل يمكن السماح لهم العوده
الى المناطق الشماليه التي اجلوا منها في
اجلوا منها في في المرحله الاولى من هذه
الحرب والقاده السياسيه القياده السياسيه
في اسرائيل ترفض ذلك في هذه المرحله بسبب
اولا ان سكان مناطق غلاف غزه من
الاسرائيليين لم يتمكنوا من العوده بعد
وهذا سيصور على انه انتصار للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه بانه تم اعاده سكان المناطق
الشماليه بينما لم يعد الاسرائيليون الى
هذه المناطق بعد ومن جهه اخرى هناك ايضا
من قال بان القياده السياسيه في اسرائيل
ستستخدم ذلك كورقه مساومه خلال المفاوضات
على صفقه تبادل هذا من جهه من جهه اخرى
هناك ايضا ايه تفكير في الجانب الاسرائيلي
بان يتم نقل النازحين الى منطقه خان يونس
بعد الانتهاء من هذه العمليات في هذه العم
مواقع لا سما وان ايضا اذاعه الجيش
الاسرائيلي قد ذكرت قبل ايام قليله بان
هناك نوع من التفاهمات
والاتفاق المبدئي مع الجانب المصري على ما
الذي لا تسمح به مصر في قضيه التعامل في
منطقه معبر رفح ومنطقه رفح وتحديدا محور
فيلادلفيا الحدود الفاصله بين فلسطين بين
غزه وشبه سيناء المصريه شكرا لك نجوان
سمري كنت معنا من r fr